una esperanza para combatir la malaria
la organización mundial de la salud
recomendó el uso de la vacuna rts s
mosquirix desarrollada por la
farmacéutica británica glaxosmithkline
this long a waits esta vacuna contra la
malaria tan esperada es un gran avance
para la ciencia la salud infantil y el
control de la enfermedad el uso de esta
vacuna además de las herramientas
existentes para prevenir la malaria
podría salvar decenas de miles de vidas
jóvenes cada año
jiang lives hitcher desde 2019 se han
administrado 2,3 millones de dosis de
moscú leaks a bebés en ghana kenia
malawi en un programa piloto a gran
escala coordinado por la ms with los
efectos más leve durante mucho tiempo
esperábamos una vacuna eficaz contra la
malaria y ahora por primera vez es
tenemos una vacuna recomendada para su
uso generalizado por lo tanto la
recomendación de hoy ofrece un rayo de
esperanza para el continente esperamos
que muchos más niños africanos estén
protegidos de paludismo y convertirse en
adultos sanos y productivos semana
la mayor mortalidad de la enfermedad es
en mayores de 5 años en 2019
386.000 murieron por el parásito que es
transmitido a las personas por las
picaduras de mosquitos infectados los
síntomas incluyen fiebre vómitos y
fatiga esta vacuna es una luz para los
miles de afectados en áfrica
subsahariana donde ocurren el 94 por
ciento de los casos del mundo